hello my name is Brett champion I'm the
visualization manager here at Wolfram
and today I'm going to be giving a very
quick and fairly scattered overview of
what is new and visualization so the
first thing I have to define is what I
consider new and I'm going to be looking
at anything that is was introduced in
version 10.1 or later so through version
11 this gives me about a year and a
half's worth of material to cover in
about 20 minutes so i'll start off with
my precious time by advertising some
related visualization talks that are
going to go into more detail on many of
these topics so immediately following my
talk min chuan is going to be talking
about improvements to the core
visualization functions plot list plot
this family of things at three-thirty
today Emanuel is going to be talking
about geo visualization jaebum is going
to be talking at five about 3d printing
normal is going to be talking at
five-thirty about date visualization
tomorrow at eleven Jeff and Keiko will
be talking about Anatomy plot 3d and on
friday at four utsu is going to be
talking about graphics 3d improvements
in general so we're going to cover a
wide range of things today going from
the basics to date and time volume
visualization geography Anatomy text
improvements to themes and we might even
get into some stuff past there if I'm
efficient enough with my time so
starting with the core functions there's
not so many new core visualization
functions but we've been sweeping back
and making passes and pushing
improvements and new options out across
all of them so the first one I want to
talk about a little bit is scaling
functions which is now so
supported by this plot dateless plot
plots and derivative functions of that
so and in addition a lot of the existing
functions that do scaling such as log
plot have switched over from sort of
independent code to relying on this
functionality that we've built into the
main plots so here we have an example
where I'm just plotting X from 1 to 100
and I've applied a log axis or a log
scale to the y axis and I've reversed
the x-axis so instead of numbers getting
larger as you go to the right they're
getting larger as you go to the left the
next one is exclusions which between
Adam before me and min after me I think
they'll both have a much wider and
cooler set of examples the key part as
far as I'm concerned for a lot of people
is going to be that you know for simple
functions like 1 over X or tangent of X
we're now going to be showing we're now
detecting where those singularities are
and are able to remove the lines it
would have been present in previous
versions in version 10.4 we added a new
option plot labels and this applies to
plot list plot dateless plot the log
variants eventually we hope to push it
out to some of the parametric plot and
maybe even some surfaces but we have to
figure out exactly how we're going to do
some labeling in those cases requires a
bit more research so this is an option
and we just say what our labels are very
similar to legends in this case and then
by default is just going to put them
down the right-hand side of our plot
labels sort of labeling the curves
directly in version 11 we introduced
call out and I'm Sherman is going to
talk about this in much more detail in
the meantime I've
stolen what I think is the best example
for my talk and so this is a rapper that
works within plot let's plot a lot of
the curve generators the basic syntax is
the thing that you want to apply the
call-out to whether it's a point or a
line what you want the call out to be in
this case it's the same thing where you
want it and then I've just got a bunch
of styling options including an
appearance option that says I wanted to
look sort of like a balloon and then
each of those curves is getting a fairly
fancy looking box identifying it yes
that is automatically being done in
traditional form yes and men will go
into that more if you in this case I've
just said above and below and it's
automatically looking at the curve and
trying to figure out where a good
position above it or a good position
below it is based on where the other
curves are and where extremas are and
that sort of thing so now moving on to
date and time so here we have well we'll
start with timeline plot which is
introduced in version 10.1 I have an
association of the release dates for
versions of Mathematica you need to
update the documentation with the most
recent releases I think the example on
the timeline Doc's currently stops at
10.3 and so here we have all of those
releases all arranged on a time axis and
they're sort of cleverly routed so that
all the labels line up fairly nicely
both vertically and horizontally it
supports multiple different types of
layouts and so if i switch to packed
then
the labels are a little bit more tightly
spaced to each other and you can really
see you know where we've started ramping
up the release process in the last
couple of years another time and date
visualization that we've added recently
is dates histogram so here I've used new
in version 11 i think function called
file system map to get the creation
dates of all the notebooks on in my
desktop and i'm limiting it to stuff
after 2010 just to make it slightly more
interesting i think so there's about a
thousand files and we could say create a
histogram by year and it's going to show
me that in general that's been
increasing and I'm you know about 2,200
notebooks that I've put on my desktop so
far today within various folder
structures and whatnot I don't have a
thousand notebooks just all thrown
together on my desktop in fact my
desktop is completely empty at the
moment except for the toxin conferences
notebook fits I didn't dare move but the
cool thing about date histogram is we
also added this date reduction option
which allows us to say things like all
weeks are the same and we just want to
look within that set of dates when am i
creating notebooks by day of the week or
within a day what times and I creating
notebooks so most of my notebooks get
created in the afternoon but between 11
and 12 I'm really productive and the
other one that I was introduced in 10.3
is dateless step plots this is similar
to date list plot with interpolation
order goes to zero except that it's
going to automatically
extend out so that on that last data
point and so here we have the top 10
girls names from the US census or the
census or maybe it's social security I
forget to gathers that data and it had
changed since I last ran this a couple
months ago so Harper was not originally
on the list so we must have gotten
updated data at some point recently so
anyway then we rank them and now we get
you know sort of very nice step plots
and you can see that Emily was really
popular number 140 10 years or something
maybe almost 15 but has taken a steep
dive in the last seven or eight years
and so now Emma's at the top so now
we'll look at volume visualization at
the conference last year they put me on
a stool and spun me around and took a
scan of my head it took a long time to
get the results out of the geometry team
but eventually they did give it to me
and so now we can do things like this so
I have density plot 3d of some function
that is rather arbitrary and not a
little flattering to my appearance but I
can plot over my over my head and not
just over the surface of my head but
over the volume encased by my head and
shoulders this function and sort of see
what happens internally for this
function over space and not I didn't
turn the legend on so this isn't
immediately obvious but in addition to
using color we're also using opacity and
so we're picking out what areas we think
are sort of most
twisting and by most interesting by
default it's what's the smallest range
of values that covers the largest amount
of volume and so those we make more
opaque everything else we make nearly
transparent and so in this case you sort
of see blue you know dark blue blobs and
sort of dark yellowy orange regions that
are more opaque and in the case of this
function that is our near 1 and minus 1
we also introduce slice plots for so the
underscores here represent density
contour and vector i'm looking at
density and we can take that same
function and look at what does it look
like on different surfaces within that
volume so we're looking at various fixed
values of x still within my head and
shoulders and look at what the density
what a normal density plot looks like on
those surfaces and then for fun we can
combine them and sort of see where so if
you look sort of down here near my left
shoulder you can sort of see where
there's a more opaque blue region and it
matches up nicely with the blue density
in on the surface on the slice surface
so now into 10.4 moving on to geography
we introduce dynamic Geographics so this
behaves largely with the same syntax as
Geographics the static version except
that i can zoom in pan so here we have a
path that takes us from Miami to Seattle
making sure to show the entire us
because otherwise it would clip off main
and probably parts of Pennsylvania and
if I've done this well my data is
already cached so I'm not relying on
on the network network was okay and I
can sort of zoom in to see well we just
skirt around paducah kentucky cut up
through Illinois for a little bit and
then head over to st. Louis and in
version 11 we introduced geo histogram
so here I have a data set that has a
little bit over four thousand locations
in the continental US and by default
we're using a hexagonal binning to show
where more of those points are where
fewer those points are so there's sort
of big clusters in New York so that's
i'm sure the tooltip is not legible so
that's around 300 slightly lower but
still over 300 for chicago 213 for
Denver Southern California 224 but the
bidding for this is very flexible Manuel
will go into it in a lot more detail but
we can also say that I want my bins to
be US states in which case then it will
take those 4,000 points figure out which
state each of them is in and color the
state directly in this version you get
something that ends up looking so it's
similar to a cheetah geo region value
plot accept that that requires you to
have already done the counting yourself
this is just taking the raw points doing
the counting and generating a
similar-looking graphic so now moving on
to Anatomy which was interested in
version 11 as I mentioned excuse me as i
mentioned Jeff and Keiko will be talking
about this more this is a relatively
complicated example to start with the
basic ideas are I want muscles to be
cyan and they're going to get cut by a
plane cut away by a plane at some point
the skin is going to be a nice bright
green again the skin is going to get cut
away at a different point
and the bones are going to be orange and
everything else is going to be
transparent and for that we're going to
show your left arm including the skin
and so then we end up with sort of a
very alien looking person I was actually
sort of going alien Halloween's coming
up trying to make something that was a
bit unusual not at all life like if you
really look like this go see a doctor
I'm sure they're gonna want to write
articles about you so then moving on
quickly to visualization around texts so
believe it or not in version 10.1 we
introduced a function called word cloud
you may not have seen these before I
think there are some people's favorite
visualization to use when they can't
think what else to use for various
domains so anyway we got the text of the
Rays of the Raven by Edgar Allan Poe
threw it into word cloud in it throws a
big Nevermore right there in front of us
which is nice but there's more
interesting things that you can do like
you can take a picture of a raven and
use that as a mask then it magically
changes the colors too or maybe not
magically and and so now we fit then
we've constrained the word cloud to be
around this image of the bird and
hopefully it's still sort of visible you
don't get quite the resolution words are
stubborn that way if you want the words
inside the bird you color negate your
mask so that it's a white bird inside of
a black background and that's what you
end up with
so we also this is perhaps stretching
the definition of visualization a little
bit but added a function that will do
sentence diagramming so what's a verb
what's a noun what's an adjective it was
not my favorite task to do in school so
once again we'll feed it you know the
first sentence of the Raven it's styled
it a little bit and so and then it goes
off and does its thing I have some
quibbles with how it's classified some
of these words that like I don't think
dreary is a verb in this context and i
think i'm pretty sure that pondered is
not an adjective so it is marked
experimental so anyway moving on to
themes we're getting close so jaebum
we'll talk more about 3d printing in
general but one of the things we did is
added plot themes to make it easier to
create printable plots the two main ones
are filled surface and thick surface
which hopefully it's fairly obvious with
each of those is done in self
explanatory we added more auto
completions for plot themes and so if i
delete this and hit command k to bring
up the list this is basically what it
looks like in version 10 except that now
it has these little arrows down at the
bottom and from there you can get a much
more complete list of not just the main
themes but also the secondary ones so if
i want to
do this as a filled surface say then
that's there as an option we also added
themes for gages to make the styling of
them easier for meshes which Charles if
you were here for his talk mentioned as
well and for graphs so just about
everything visual supports themes at the
moment and the ones that don't should be
getting them soon and so that's
everything I put in the overview but
wait there's more so there's also with
the addition of the new audio objects
different ways of visualizing audio
waveforms dendrograms for looking at
clustering of things we added icons as
various forms of entities and so you can
get in icon for a lighthouse or an
airplane and include it on a map easily
using geo marker and then rule plot for
looking at various computational systems
like cellular automata in 1d and 2d
Turing machines substitution systems and
there's probably some that I'm
forgetting and that really is the end
then so thank you